[Music]
and we thank you for joining us at 11 a
community mourns tonight after the death
of former zappos ceo tony shea
the dtp company formerly known as the
downtown project which shea founded back
in 2012 made that announcement tonight
they say shea died peacefully with
family by his side in connecticut
it also included a statement from his
family saying in part quote
tony's kindness and generosity touched
the lives of everyone around him
and forever brightened the world
delivering happiness was
always his mantra shea was often called
a visionary but he didn't start out that
way he once said his passion for
business
didn't begin with shoes but with
earthworms and when that didn't pay off
he tried other things
bought a bunch of them and thought i
could grow them and produce more worms
but
that didn't quite work out they all
escaped there was the lemonade stand
there was this small mail order
button business where i would make the
buttons that people pin on
after graduating from harvard he created
and sold a website with his roommate and
made 265 billion dollars
after that he invested that money into a
small company called zappos back in 1999
but it grew quickly soon after and moved
its headquarters to henderson
in 2004 and eventually was bought by
amazon in 2009
our own ted florendo got to speak with
shea back in 2012 and talked about
his goals and success consider yourself
ambitious
at all i guess i wouldn't say
ambitious more probably just the type of
person that gets bored easily
that same year shea founded the downtown
project with a mission of
revitalizing the downtown las vegas area
he put 350 million dollars into real
estate
entertainment and tech startups around
fremont street and helped develop
container park with the famous
fire-breathing praying mantis he stepped
down and retired from zappos back in
august
his friends say he was a forward thinker
who saw happiness ahead of dollars
and that he truly believed in people's
passions and achieving
excellence it's really about
talking through the hard moments
persistence and resilience
play a big role and i think a lot of
people actually do give up
too early with anyone especially youth
to
you know don't self-limit
your world of possibilities there's
always ways to think bigger or think
differently
governor sysolak offered his condolences
tonight saying shea played a pivotal
role in transforming downtown and sent
his
and the first lady's love to the shea
family and casino mogul derrick stevens
also tweeting out tonight saying that he
and the community
would miss tony shea greatly he also
noted that she
changed the landscape of the support and
the people
in it